Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today, we're going to crush some soda cans.
In the footage that you see here, the animations
are performed by an already existing algorithm
for thin shell deformations, and for a complete
sensorial experience, this piece of work aims
synthesize sound for these phenomena.
Sounds for crumpling up all kinds of candy
wraps, foils, and plastic bags.
A lofty, noble goal, loving it.
However, this problem is extraordinarily difficult.
The reason is that these crumpling simulations
are amazingly detailed, and even if we knew
all the physical laws for the sound synthesis,
which is already pretty crazy, it would still
be a fruitless endeavor to take into consideration
every single thing that takes place in the
simulation.
We have to come up with ways to cut corners
to decrease the execution time of our algorithm.
Running a naive, exhaustive search would take
tens of hours for only several seconds of
footage.
And the big question is, of course, what can
we do about it?
And before we proceed, just a quick reminder
that the geometry of these models are given
by a lot of connected points that people in
computer graphics like to call vertices.
The sound synthesis takes place by observing
the changes in the stiffness of these models,
which is the source of the crumpling noise.
Normally, our sound simulation scales with
the number of vertices, and it is abundantly
clear that there are simply too many of them
to go through one by one.
To this end, we should strive to reduce the
complexity of this problem.
First, we start with identifying and discarding
the less significant vibration modes.
Beyond that if in one of these vertices, we
observe that a similar kind of buckling behavior
is present in its neighborhood, we group up
these vertices into a patch, and we then forget
about the vertices and run the sound synthesis
on these patches.
And of course, the number of patches is significantly
less than the number of vertices in the original
model.
In this footage, you can see some of these
patches.
And it turns out that the execution time can
be significantly decreased by these optimizations.
With these techniques, we can expect results
in at least 5 times quicker, but if we're
willing to introduce slight degradations to
the quality of the sounds, we can even go
10 times quicker with barely perceptible changes.
To evaluate the quality of the solutions,
there is a user study presented in the paper.
And the pinnacle of all tests is of course,
when we let reality be our judge.
Everything so far sounds great on paper, but
how does it compare to what we experience
in reality?
Wow.
Truly excellent results.
Suffice to say, they are absolutely crushing
it.
And we haven't even talked about stochastic
enrichment and how one of these problems can
be solved optimally via dynamic programming.
If you're interested, make sure to have a
look at the paper!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!